right
good evening to everybody
um
well
welcome to the meeting and
um this is our first uh scrutiny meeting
um in the new year so can I wish you all
a very happy New Year
um
we've got the agenda here I know that
councilor Carter just wanted to say a
few words about the agenda
thank you um it's kind of around
Administration and it's kind of a
frustration it'd be interesting anybody
else shares this but every time we come
here you click on something and
there's not the whole deck you have to
open different things and dance between
packs every organization that I've ever
reported to or run has never done that
and we get
documents added as in we haven't when
this stuff's delivered there's things
been coming and they'll and they'll come
later could we have a deadline no later
than Friday of the Friday before the
meeting for all reports because for
people who work they do this on a
weekend so getting something on a Monday
is it absolutely no use whatsoever to
you if you want to be diligent so could
we a when we sit here have a whole lot
on one link and be
can we have a deadline of it is not in
by Friday it doesn't go please I think
um
there is a particular reason I think um
this time around around uh Christmas
um
and
um it's been difficult to get the
reports back from the chief officers uh
in in the time that we would like to do
that I think Alex does the best that he
can in terms of
sending those late reports out and then
tries to tie them up with the other
reports and I think he sent an email out
yesterday which did exactly that a late
report and
um you know the
uh the agenda items and the other
reports were all tied into that as well
and so that was yesterday that you did
that because I
I and I I confessed that since I did all
my prep for this meeting I haven't
opened further emails about how it might
be tidied up and if that was the case
it's probably the first time for which I
thank you but if that's a guarantee
that'd be appreciated and the final
thing is that I don't think any of us
are happy of getting late reports
um and the agenda goes out
a week
before that that is the statutory Duty
that we have to abide by that that
agenda goes out a week before to all
members
but there are late reports and I think
we we we try as hard as possibly can to
get the the officers to get those
reports ready in a timely matter but I
understand the point that you're making
because I I find it very difficult to
just go backwards and forwards looking
for emails where the reports are on but
can we set a dead agility then that says
if you don't hit this Guillotine well
then it just doesn't go that's I mean
I'm submitting a board deck next week to
the organization I work I understand
sometimes we can do that and I think a
deadline should be before at least if if
a late item is going out that it should
go out before the weekend really so that
people have a weekend and a few days or
nights to look at it so
um I absolutely agree with the points
that you make and we are trying and you
know we're reliant on the other Chief
officers as well yes Geraldine and I
think that was going to make a similar
point and I this is not in any way I
think I know Alex was a really hard job
of getting things together from a lot of
other sources uh so I really appreciate
what democratic services do here but um
one of these came at 2 30 this afternoon
which is quite a substantial document
and um and just add to what cancer
cartoon says not only people who have
other jobs but people have other
responsibilities that aren't necessarily
paid who also can't necessarily drop
everything you know at an unforeseen
time even if there was a message saying
this will be out at 2 30 on Wednesday we
could actually plan around it but um if
we have a statute duty to have the
agendas out on time are we meeting that
if we put out an agenda at this time I
had absolutely no substantive items at
all in it are we actually need to
literally have the agenda does that meet
your statutory Duty
it's fine from best practice um we do
publish them as soon as we do
um we have to publish a notification
that uh the meeting is to be conducted
five clear working days beforehand and
the items that are to be discussed and
really they should have all reports for
it that's for transparency so that not
only councils but members of the public
have time to consider everything and
um think about it before they attend the
meeting uh we have had uh previously
a a rule where if something wasn't going
to meet the deadline that it had to go
to the chief executive and they had to
clear if the reasons given for it
missing the deadline were given uh
that's something that I will take back
and I will look at um whether we can
revisit that and put that position back
in place if that's something that the
committee would like if I could reply to
that I mean in deadline if you want a
deadline for bringing things say to
council or exec with your decision
making bodies that makes sense then if
the exec don't get their act together to
bring something they don't get to bring
it through for scrutiny that could
actually be used
um to you know pause scrutiny or it
could be seen to pause scrutiny and so
actually I'd be worried about setting a
deadline for scrutiny but if there was
any way that we could have a message
saying we hope to have these two items
by Friday and this one will be really
late it might be Wednesday afternoon we
could at least plan around that
if you would like a different deadline
rather than the faculty working days
ones where there is a cut off if you if
you say Council then whatever that is
agreed I can take that back and we can
put that in
gay enforcement behind it
yeah I mean I will rehash the points
because from my group's point of view I
I'd like to further support both
people's side either side of me
um everyone in my group I believe Works
to some degree or other so it's a
struggle I'd like to raise the
repercussion
to what extent is everyone in this room
fully able to scrutinize if they haven't
been able to look at them I think we it
it diminishes the work that this
committee does
yeah I I like to do it agree with you
and you know I'm I'm asking all the time
where's the reports
um
and
um you know if they're not ready they're
not ready and I I can't personally do
anything about that but I think it can
be raised at a high level really to make
sure that you know the they they the
reports do come in a timely matter
um yeah I think last last speaker on
this Jill you wanted to come in yeah
I've already asked Alice about minute
minutes as well because I'm aware that
we get the minutes you know right the
last minute and we really kind of need
to be checking that things are being
followed up and stuff and I know that he
said that it wasn't possible because we
need to put all the you know um
distribute all the papers together but I
was wondering if we could have site of
the minutes as a group possibly
afterwards meeting before they're
actually officially published is that a
possibility
foreign
comes down to capacity a lot of time
it's um but yeah ideally we aim to have
them done within two weeks it's just uh
at the moment with other services we've
been running uh
about
two members of Staff down at the moment
and so I've seen a number of committees
and whilst I know the minutes are
important and everything it's a juggling
of priorities and unfortunately they
tend to get pushed back but it's
something that we are aware of and uh we
are always striving to do um
better if we can but uh yes they should
be you should have access to a draft
um copy within two uh two weeks of the
meeting is what we've tried to do is
best practice but I'd say
um we have one
yeah I've been struggling with capacity
at the moment so
you understand yeah I mean I think that
is a real issue the fact that the
Democratic services are down officers
and that puts an enormous pressure on
the existing officers I think that's
trying trying to resolve that situation
and hopefully uh we we will do that
right can we now go on to the uh agenda
items I am going to change
um the the order because I've been
requested the budget scrutiny uh will
now come after the item four uh
questions from the public
um so item one is attendances do we have
any apologies I know councilor Walsh
gave his apologies because he has
another meeting to attend
um that was planned quite a while ago
I've also received apologies from
councilor Denise Weston right
okay
um
right item two is the minutes
um
can we agree those minutes yeah Joe yeah
it does say in there that like um
Communications plan for the climate
change action plan the greater
Manchester action plan were going to be
shared and they haven't been as far as I
can recall they haven't so I just wanted
to raise that thank you
[Music]
I'll chase that up with jazz twitt
councilor win Stanley
uh thank you chair just a point mention
to Alex beforehand there's an email due
to go to the um the place team regarding
an outstanding issue and the
um disability access tax companies group
it'd be great if that could be centers
as soon as thank you thank you
and yep I'll pick that out first thing
tomorrow
okay
can we agree those minutes
yeah everybody happy thank you
um Now we move on to item three which is
Declarations of interest does anybody
have any Declarations of interest in any
of the items
no
um item four is the questions
um I think we have Mr Donnelly here
Stuart uh what do you like to just come
and sit down
um there yeah yeah
foreign
this one yeah there we go okay so my
question
um my name is Stuart Donnelly and I'm a
resident from gorse Hill
um following the complaints from local
residents regarding how traffic Council
and greater Manchester police deal with
match days in the Stratford area on the
7th of December 2021 the gorso branch of
Stratford and ermstein conservative
Association launched a campaign to
collect residents views on what they are
experiencing
the information would then be presented
to the relevant authorities with a call
to action seven days later on the 14th
of December 2021 Trafford Council
announced that it would start to take
action against anti-social Behavior
associated with match days
with an event that Old Trafford tasks
and Finnish group having been
established can the chair of the view
please tell me where local residents can
find minutes of what is being discussed
on their behalf at review meetings
especially as the terms of the reference
state that meetings are conducted in a
fair and transparent business-like
fashion and secondly having originally
raised the issue on behalf of the
residents of gorse Hill conservatives
our request the ghost Hill conservatives
are requesting to be a stakeholder in
the review and can the chair tell me if
he's agreeable to that request thank you
yeah thank you very much for for raising
that
um
councilor Walsh obviously who does chair
the Tuscan finish group has given his
apologies for tonight because they've
got another engagement time
and I think uh so so I I will stand in
in terms of the councilor Walsh
um I think you're aware that the task
and Finnish group has been set up by the
scrutiny committee and apart from uh
executive members all members of council
were invited to sit on the task and
finish group and it is a cross-party
group of members
um you do mention that gorse Hill uh
conservatives are requesting to be
stakeholdered in the review clearly your
group are welcome to
feed into the Tuscan finish group and
like other interested parties businesses
and residents you can do that through
our scrutiny officer
Alex
and
there are records of task and finish
activity and these are
presented
to the committee to enable members of
the committee to track processes
these trackers are usually published on
the agenda which go out to the public
and the task and finish group are not a
decision-making committee however it
does report to this committee
as it progresses through their work and
I think that's an important point that
um
anything that is agreed would have to
come to this committee which
um is streamed live
um so that there are ways a means of the
public being able to
um you know share with us
um the reports that we we do have and
ultimately uh when when we complete that
task and finish work a report will go to
the executive with recommendations on
that because they are the
decision-making body ultimately at the
Council on actions that may be taken
um so I think I think
um you know
the group that you represent
um you do have members actually on this
on this as well so you can feed into
them as well as into Alex and you can
feeding to me as well
um
and I'm sure that councilor Walsh
would would uh endorse that so thank
thanks for raising it
um and I don't know whether you've got
any other comments that you want to make
and yeah I think the I I I totally
support the cross party you know working
together here but you know it's like
only yesterday there was on the gorsal
labor Facebook social media page they
did a full report of what happened at
the meeting and I think it'll be better
if all the feedback was given from from
the council as one rather than you know
individual parties then feeding back
that information
well I mean I I'll answer that we you
know uh it would have been a ward
counselor that have given that
information yeah and that you know that
that is something that I think all
councilors do uh to to actually keep
their uh residents in form so I don't
think there's a a point about that
sorry I think there's a little bit of a
cross
um
uh communication going on here uh those
other meetings uh meetings that are
organized by
um Manchester United Football Club with
Ward councils to inform the community
whereas the testing finish group that
we've set up is
um separate from that that's just the
council doing their own piece of work
and led by the council and those other
meetings like with if they have been
shared that information by the world
councils that's come separately to like
the council's standard business economy
okay or the work of this committee yeah
okay well thank thanks for raising it no
thank you thank you for your time okay
thank you
you're welcome to stay in the meeting if
you're so rich
right so uh can we move on to the uh
finance
budget uh did
clearly in in the report we we we put a
draft report
um that will go to the executive I don't
know whether you wanted to speak to that
or whether they wanted to update us
thank you thank you very much chair and
thank you for moving the agenda around
that is for Graham's benefit so he can
get a a relatively early night which I
think he deserves so um I'll stay on for
a little I'll stay on for a little
longer
whether
thank you very much for that um I think
it might be helpful if um a I give a bit
of an update as to what's happened since
we were last sat around a table and B I
can very briefly comment on the uh the
the draft report that the committee put
together
um so I'll start with the the update
first of all so we have had now the um
the Autumn statement and the settlement
um overall positive movement for us
since the uh the the budget Gap at
October of 8.5 million key headline is
that we've got an increase in our core
spending power of 9.3 which is uh
considerable though not as much as
inflation
um there's going to be as part of the
core spending part of the Assumption is
that council tax referendum limits well
the reference limit is 2.99 plus two
percent for the adult social care
precept
um we're going to be seeing new support
for for social care of 4.8 million
pounds which is unring fenced plus 3.4
million pound ring fence to support
Market sustainability and the hospital
discharge program and we'll see that
going into future years as well and
there's some adult sources so adult
social charging reform is going to be
deferred for a minimum of two years
which in some respects gives stability
in other respects obviously causes
issues for a situation that needs
resolving around adult social care fees
and payments
um in terms of other aspects the 100
business rate retention scheme has been
extended to 23 24 which is good news
from our perspective so in all
um we have some respite we're doing the
final numbers which we're checking for
the robustness of the uh the budget that
we wish to present to Council next month
um the current Gap is around 4 million
so we're obviously considering ways that
we now close that Gap and balance the
budget for the year
um in terms of the the report I have
read the report I have to say I think
it's a
very good report I think it sets out the
Independence that scrutiny has and it's
uh suggests a number of very um very
good suggestions and some very good um
you know points for us to come back on
in future meetings and updates that we
will happily provide to the scrutiny
committee so before I am quiet I just
like to say once again to everyone
around this table and anyone who's been
involved in the security process thank
you it's turning in to be a a constant
process through the year we're almost
there and I really do and I know Graham
also really appreciates the input that
you've had as part of the budget process
so thank you very much chair
that's a very good question
um we haven't had any kind of extra
consideration but ears are open at uh
the department so we are in continuing
um engaging with them I'm sure Graeme
would like to add something from an
officer perspective to that as well
yeah nothing nothing direct and nothing
additional to what's been announced but
it's what we got just before Christmas
was the provisional settlement
on which government asked for comments
to that consultation so they will
um listen to consultation points and
then do a final settlement in early
February and I did see that the F20
group has drafted and we've got I've got
in my inbox of circulation from the f20s
their response to the settlement again
repeating that same message to please
look after authorities who were law
funded like the rest of the F20 so
that'll go out as part of the
consultation response to the settlement
from the F20
and I think if scrutiny found it helpful
and if we're able to we'd be happy to to
share anything that we can about the F20
campaign and the lobbying that's
happening
right thanks thank you for that it is no
questions around that update
clearly the scrutiny report that will be
presented to the executive
um it's not next Monday the Monday
afternoon
um it is a draft
um
set of proposals
and members obviously will need to agree
or disagree or raise points on that so
we can amend mend it if if so wish I
know Dylan's got a question
thank you chair
um amongst the recommendations there was
the item eight uh on on the list on the
list yeah which was around the dimming
of Street lighting yeah and he was
asking uh system
to scrutiny for increase any increasing
accidents in being identified I just saw
that I mean
I think a more concern issue would be
things like increasing crime uh I mean I
was actually which the streets being
dimmed uh normally I mean like country
lanes you hardly have any lighting
people have got headlights uh
I I don't see that being as much as
perhaps the concern about
the potential increase in crime from
diminishing the like something it could
be a false economy to a certain extent
because obviously in the crime is
increasing across greater Manchester
obviously there's lots of pressures on
people as well and it it's like an
aggravated crime as well and it it has
uh impact on uh you know the
traumatizing victims and families and a
wider problem it can cause which can
then
create pressures on social services and
those other things so I think there's
I do feel that we should add something
in there about the potential increase in
crime that that would
have
uh and we should be able to equally sort
of report on get some report on that and
how much that will affect it over
re reword it
um because I think if if we get lots of
complaints of concerns
around the dimming of lighting then we
should
um you know raise that with with the
exec
um and uh to you know look again at at
that if we do get
um you know those concerns coming into
us hard and fast and so we can just
re-reach that yeah Chris
thanks chair
um I just uh just just one comment on
that that as part of that saving there's
an equality
um impact assessment that we do uh that
said that's that's key to it when we
talk about dimming and we talk about
switching off we're not talking about
everywhere um without in any high impact
area then then that one that won't take
place and those details will be released
when we uh when we do when we uh when we
move through the through the process
yeah I think it was just if there was a
an impact then you know we'd want that
um looking at uh very closely because we
don't want to put people into any kind
of danger whatsoever
yeah Steve just briefly chat to what
Chris has commented mostly however that
we're looking at is a as you will be
aware uh up to a few years ago what we
sort of started using LED lighting and
these unlike the old style lights
actually instantly instantly come on
whereas uh under the old style lights
they had to allow an hour in in the
regime writing regime for those to
actually switch on onto each full
illumination but with LED we don't need
to do that anymore but it's actually
it's not until now we've actually
considered that should have actually
probably been discussed at the time and
done but obviously yeah it's now and
obviously uh we don't need that extra
mile on it they have to do it so it's
about the consideration of that what
we've done obviously done it carefully
what is it an hour that simply uh when
the writing's already there it is
instant that was it wasn't previously so
it's certainly one of the things that we
looked at though as part of that was
even if you set up with him that Chris
has commented about the various aspects
how it relates to the impact assessments
yeah I mean we we were made aware of
that that you know that first hour you
know wouldn't be needed so that would
save some of the resource but it don't
also talked about around the dimming so
um there was you know there were
concerns from members around that and I
think we uh wanted it to ensure that we
do monitor any complaint that we might
get and then
uh clearly we we would wish to act on
that as far as we're concerned so we
will just reword that
um to to make it
um knowing that if we received the
concerned whatever those concerns are we
will look at yeah yes in
um minor Corrections a minor but
important one is is in um number three
there's a word missing there really it
should say that a report be provided to
health scrutiny if there is a
significant increase in the number of
residents counseling care so just that's
what the notes further on bear out but
there's a recommendation to you talking
about yes yeah that a report be provided
help yeah it's just the word if needs
adding in there it's
yeah
if a significantly if you get the point
yeah have you got that are we yeah
um is there anything else within the
report that anybody wants to raise uh if
not
um we can sign it off uh tonight and
we'll we'll all agree uh with with those
minor changes yeah okay well thanks
thanks very much
um and we'll relieve you too now
all right okay
thank you Graham for coming along
um right we we now move on to
um the
High amp
um and I think we're going to get a
presentation I think people have
received did did people receive the
shortened version that did
come to date basically
um
yeah
so
uh who's going to lead it Chris are you
uh with myself and um and Les diagonal
who's our principal engineering manager
for um uh for one Trafford
um first of all I'd like to offer my
apologies to the uh to the scrutiny
committee for the likeness of the uh of
the summer report uh one of the reasons
for that is Christmas and and so on in
terms of in some sickness but one of the
other major problems
is that the the highways infrastructure
Asset Management plans are moving Feast
um it moves every day in terms of the in
terms of uh the the condition of uh
condition that we've got and I think
um in the main document uh there's 60
something slides of detail around around
what to what is the biggest asset that
the uh that the council owns uh and its
various and its various elements
um what we did take the decision to do
was to simplify it slightly for uh for
delivery in this in delivery in this
meeting and that's the major cause for
the uh for the delay so my apologies for
that but you have got the basic the the
base information as well to uh to go
through and and digest in the initial uh
in the initial submission but also you
get a copy as you've got today of the
slightly simplified with with
recommendations at the end of it
um the simplified version I'm afraid is
still 20 uh 25 pages long so so you can
see that it is a fairly weighty document
that we're dealing with
um
every year we every year we present uh
around the asset management plan and one
thing I will say um initially is that
this is as near as news we can get a
statement of fact so it's it's a
statement of fact about the condition of
the road as it stands at this moment in
time in 2023
so uh so from that we utilize utilize
that to to make decisions around the
budget uh um around our budget needs for
uh for each of the uh each of the
different assets that are contained
within it
so realistically What Les will take us
through is is the facts of around where
we are with uh with our asset management
plan and then at the end we have uh we
have some some of the uh some of the
summarizer summarization uh which wasn't
in the initial initial pack which are
recommendations about about how the
decisions have been been made to go
forward with the budget
so without further ado
thank you Chris thank you
um
all right
all right
um I said trying to do condensed version
I'll try and save my voice and
everyone's ears as well
um right quick introductions obviously
um what we're going to do in this whole
process is go through to a bit of a feed
into the information and of course it's
already done stuff I'll tell you what
the hemp is and you know what it's all
about
the asset principles life cycling plan
Etc what we've done to date as a
consequence of some of the works has
been done on us
um we'll review some of the asset
management models that we produce you
know we can produce millions of
different models with different
solutions and different outcomes
um and then we'll come up with the
recommendations and summary of what that
actually means to us all
foreign
Asset Management plan is basically a
component part of three elements the
parts the policy strategy and plan so
it's having to basically do as such it
documents how we approach things such as
the public this is a public um documents
as well
um it covers all highways assets
um to different degrees you know
honestly about data we have on things
um and what the the original plan
um didn't include is things like carbon
Etc so this is quite a major review what
we've got it's bringing it forward it's
also dealing with some of the challenges
we've got and we've got substances and
um deterioration of the network is a
consequence of some quite severe winter
we've had recently as well
foreign
TI side will sort of spend that sort of
element of work but what comes to me and
my team and Remus is the plan
maintenance the capital analyst of it
which is a combination of different
grants that we get through yourselves
through other departments to tfgm as
examples
including non-violence agencies we've
recently had success with
environmentation business works as well
um I'm gonna put some past and present
uh successes that have come through
2018-19 we have the DFT portal which is
a million pounds
um that hasn't reappeared since 2018
there's not been any of those portals
bids coming out or grants everyone else
but we do have what we now
uh commonly called across the the city
center regen uh strategic funding for
which was the key root network has
gained 4.5 million pounds of Investments
which you'll see going to ground in the
next three months
um to on the highway itself and a
further two million pounds worth of
investment is going to go into
structures as such
um
some of the successes we've done today
we've now developed a better strategy
than where we were in the past with long
term strategies better understanding of
the asset is part of that
um in 2021
um I think unfortunately we had a
situation where we started monitoring
you know from day one and we'll show you
this later on that there was a um the
u-class network which is your
residential residential AIDS mainly for
the majority I bought this 90 to 97 of
the network is impacted by this and we
ended up with a situation where it
literally just fell off the edge it's
gone from five percent to 24.5 in red
there's a significant change
um in the meantime whilst there's always
been you know the things we've been
doing we've done done debates has
already mentioned and we initially
started in contact with a 10 million
pound investment in Street lightning to
make things LED do 23 000 units replaced
with LED units
um and these are these are lamps these
are not the whole columns this is not
the Steels that standard standard Etc
it's a 27 000 LED lamps
um and we've continued to invest in that
um accumulating Investments of over a
million pound a year now in recent years
driven very much by the Reds uh from the
same asset
yeah I think one of the one of the
really big wins of the LED has come um
um has come actually in the last six to
seven months
um the electricity charge H that that
we've been through that we're all
suffering from
um would have had a uh a would have not
something along the lines of 1.82
million pounds
um out of the budget uh in terms of in
terms of electricity electricity Supply
so I've indicates the uh have indicates
the move there with the LED but also
um we have got a remainder
um it's a very small remainder of uh of
lights but we'll be looking to uh
looking to to move those into LED as
soon as we possibly can
[Music]
foreign
like for likes an interesting one uh
depending on the depending on the on the
on the area that it that it is
normally we would be looking to to
change all of the sock lanterns the the
original salt Lancers to to LED
um depending on the particular area and
depending on the on the on the need in
it acts I know there are demands demands
for certain uh certain levels of uh
levels of kits to uh to go in certain
areas which we look at in a case-by-case
basis the um in terms of moving
everything from a sock Lantern which
were the original ones to LED we'd be
looking to complete that not only
because LED is actually more efficient
but also because the supply of salt
lanterns now the LED has become so um
has become so uh prevalent if you like
uh in the in the industry fast and when
something dwindles the price of it goes
uh it goes up as well so uh so we have
we have to look at that
um and realistically
um we're looking to change every Lantern
London to uh to LED in the length of the
contract
um I mean on um how we gather data now
that this part is very much focused on
the highways and the footways
um and how it's dealt with it feeds into
the DFT
um and it feeds into the need for us to
actually uh do Hogan with account
returns Etc
there's a very technical system that
comes behind it there's a system called
scanner which is driven vehicle with all
these wonderful sensors on it that tells
the conditions of roads and life
expectancies are developed we've got
um cdis and dvi's basically CVI is a
course visual inspection and DVI a
detailed visual inspection it is
literally someone walking and assessing
it on a form as a scoring system in a
sense looking for defects Etc
we have the Footwear Network surveys
that's pure as it says it's footwears
similar sort of system marked on a
specific process of recognize best
practice
um we have the defects that have been
identified measures from there so
there's different formats different
scores that will relate to that
um and then it all goes into a black box
called um Horizons uh there's a number
of different formats but basically this
comes and scores it in a particular way
that tells you what's your what's your
worst what's your best
and from that you end up with a list
call it your top 100 but you're talking
thousands of particular aspects in here
it takes accounts of a number of other
aspects as well hierarchy being one of
them Etc
foreign
Network in the sense of we've got a
ghost value 1.64 billion the last time
the numbers were run the numbers have
been run again because the data is live
all the time we've got some further
dates that's coming in November we'll be
running that through the systems the
Canada's way alone 1.20 billion big
numbers
um and obviously a growing number as
well in the sense that we are now
getting development sites successfully
into into Trafford at a greater rate
than that for a number of years so that
network is going to start building again
um there's a breakdown in that obviously
you can see from the chart there there's
different classifications and Roads view
classification the unclassified Road
networks we identified the significant
parts of that Network
um each year we do a return as I said to
government we also do what's called an
incentive fund which goes to government
which is part of a grant that we get
from the DFT
if we're not successful we basically end
up with the incentive fund is you get
you score out of 20 Questions they're
not simply just 22 questions there's a
lot of paperwork that goes behind them
evidence bias Etc we work with greater
management Partnerships and some of that
because that gets us extra points you
abandon from one two or three
if you're coming at three you get 100
Grand if you come without two you'll get
30 if you're coming at one
they'll just stop when giving you money
until you actually do some action plan
so this asset management is a must do
and is the most recognized sort of
product that we have to do hence the
reason it's quite a a strong and very
um heavily invested in process
the approaching obviously continues so
there's a whole sort of remix of
guidance these are the two key guides
that we do and that everyone refers to
as the Bible is what we should be doing
how we should be doing Etc
um now from a point of the process it
goes through from the surveys so
analysis to checks to end up with an end
program
what we try to do is inconvenience
intervene something and convenient
intervene uh with the life cycle as you
can see from the left-hand side there
what's happening is the condition of
that asset is deteriorating slowly so
when we intervene at the first point
where it Peaks again we invest in it
it'll bring it back up the level to the
green hopefully
that slides again we've reintervened so
that's the whole process of a life cycle
you know a road is designed 25 or 40
years of life expectancy most roads are
older than that doesn't mean at the end
of 40 years it's not a road it still has
a service life value and that goes back
to the Holcomb's account element of it
um the bit on the right basically shows
you how it sort of fits in a different
way so that it gain some of the process
that is
um I I think what type of processes you
would do from this particular thing uh
you know from an early intervention
could be just a service treatment we've
been very successful with the Six
Million Pound we've invested at the
moment on treatments there is also the
Reds and unfortunately they're the ones
that are causing us the bigger costs
because it's made into interventions
into the carriageways digging Etc
is an example of the profiles we've got
the Vogue classifications
as you can see this is what I was
emphasizing about the u-class network
since 2019 it's it's literally gone off
the edge you will know from 2022 to 2023
it drops back that's because of the Six
Million Pound investment we're finally
getting Returns what it has to be done
is stopped that going any further the
expectation without intervention will be
looking at 30 this year
we've actually reduced it why at the end
of this 1.6 from where we started from
now bear in mind it's two years we're
roughly about six percent increase we'll
be getting at the moment so it's quite a
significant um return on what we've got
um
just a little bit of emphasis on that
really
um the slide before it
um laid out where we intervene uh and
the further we go down into the red part
if you like from the green to the yellow
to the red
he's in in simple terms the the more it
costs us to intervene so uh so if we get
down to the red then it costs quite a
lot to work a lot to go into it's a
pretty it's a it's a deep
um and it's a deep relay of of what
we're what we were doing
um if you go just the next slide yeah
in the in 2016 17 18 and 19 funding
levels were at the funding levels that
they were and uh and realistically we
got to make choices now the
um a b and c uh C classification
percentage-wise covers 21 of the network
but it covers 21 of the network which is
at the highest speeds with the most uh
with the most usage with bus usage and
with uh and and effectively in the main
roads
so the intervention level based around
based around safety uh to to do that
which is the reason that that most of
the spend was on that a b can see
in 2019 2020 2021
um our Interventional intervention
levels on the u-class network because
the amount of money uh was was less so
worser effectively the 79 of the uh the
network has got worse
as Les said
um that we invested three million pounds
last year in
um what we've called surface dressing
which was actually micro asphalting uh
which has taken taken a goodly
proportion of the proportion of the
network
effectively that is probably the um the
least intervention that we can do it's a
it's a thin surface coating
um which will last somewhere between 7
and 15 years to uh to keep the uh to
keep the surface Integrity of what we do
so let's say
um we fill the pothole and then we
effectively protect it on top
um that was Rising exponentially
um because we weren't going into the
u-class network the effect in 2022 well
it doesn't look like it's brought it
down very much it's brought it down by
1.6 what it stopped it doing is Rising
by five and that is the that is the
major the majority of it further three
million pounds that will spare will spam
will keep that keep that away and we'll
improve the network improve the network
so it just as a just a point it shows
that the Intervention when it's when
it's properly put in uh put in place can
actually stop a deteriorating Network
getting worse
um it's just needed to be emphasized it
emphasized that the the money was uh
money was was put into uh put into the
network network and what it was there to
do
[Music]
oh
and just on the y-axis there on the
other side what are the units is that
I'm sorry let's go back
yeah that's the percentage of failure no
the the other Church
oh hang on I'm looking at the long
version
okay there's no units it's a percentage
then is it there's no units
it's what percentage of the network
actually falls into that percentage of
the network thank you
and again this comes from all the the
previous mentioned cbis and scanner
details that sort of scores which is
returned to government as well on a
regular on an annual basis
um the other thing I would say about the
capital is is to remember that by the
capital Investments we're trying to
reduce the number of potholes which is a
revenue pressure
which obviously is a real concern
obviously the revenues knock on the
right way as well
um so that's the other the benefits we
try and reduce the revenue pressures
um again from a point of deterioration
modeling
um the mouse you look at this this is
purely this is purely carriageway this
is purely uh our roads and such we'll
start about just over 80 18 million
pounds worth of backlog
need of investing
Etc
now to clear that off we're not going to
get 80 million pounds we're realistic
but when you start investing over the
10-year period this model shows that at
the present time according funding this
is going to creep it may have a little
bit of a dip because of the way things
are being treated it will start timer
back up but as we do most things
42 million pounds over 10 years leaders
used to lie we actually get below
probably about seven or eight percent
to get a 10 Improvement we need 64
million pounds so 6.4 million pounds
just to deal with the present condition
on those that's taking it from a steady
state situation
by the way so I got a bit confused by
the last job so the 64 million quid is
that in one year or is that no it's a 10
year period yeah that's right with the
10 that's over the years on the graph
there yeah yeah so what the what the
graph shows is the return on your
millions of backlog so basically left
hand side is your backlog
uh and then obviously the annual yearly
sort of is the lower axis but it's over
the 10 years
yeah yeah 6.5
that's just to deal with the Canada
similarly we've got four ways obviously
Footwear is a massive in length and
basically the equivalent to drive into
Costa Del Sol and you know that's how
far we've got in four ways to be
accumulation we look at them conditioned
reports obviously similar sort of thing
this is from what they call the FNS
surveys we mentioned that I mentioned
earlier on
um
this splits the body into five areas as
you can see from the the very small map
I've had to put on to try and keep it
condensed the yellow bit is our foot
ways the bits that are blue is part of
the network without footwears
the early Express has said surveys by
five years because footwears jump
generally changing their Rapids process
of the casualty what will do so best
practice five years but we keep on
feeding the machine keep on getting the
data and billing it's not to say a bad
winter won't make a difference somewhere
but at least it's a constant process of
looking in a logical way
the other thing I would say most of the
footwears in in Trafford are blacksop
which is a fortunate thing because uh
flag football is always a risk of
displacement and one of the other
problems we do have is obviously parking
which generates issues with
um Footwear failures Etc
steady States on fortways which is the
steady state basically means where are
we in the sense of what investment we
need this as I said 18 million was the
the carriageway 14.9 million again this
is just another investment program you
could we can model any number over a
certain period of time Etc but this
again reflects steady state 1.49 million
per year will give us the flat line
your budgets then start changing with
regards to investment zero budget Red
Line 1.5 it's constantly it's going to
be struggling to go down because the
other thing is we've constantly got that
change one we fixed one we've got
another one behindi
um
before we're gone tomorrow Illuminating
matters if you like
um on Footwear on footways as well
um we haven't in terms of the amount
that's food that we spent obviously
there's a safety issue uh with with
footwears and disability issue with
footwears so so one of the things that
we will be looking at is to it is to
increase the increase the Footwear
budget going forward if possible
um which we know is in extremely
straight in times
um as we are fortunate that we have that
we have blacktop flexible so flexible
surfacing is usually better although it
can be affected by route
but we are aware that there is that
there is the disability uh ability issue
issue on this and I look at it oh
looking at our thoughtway budgets about
what about what we do obviously we'll be
dealing with small scale items which is
uh which is a problem
um
as a point oh come on for later on but
the Footwear budget is taking out the
same structural maintenance budget that
we get globally it does not stand on its
own for two feet as such streetline I
know there's obviously a lot of interest
this is the asset this is the numbers
we're talking of
27 000 units uh Street lighting alone
we've identified a further 80 feet of
pillars
um not an illuminated bollards of
reducing because we're getting rid of
the electric driven ones where you're
going to solar so there's a problem of
work that's going on with that
um which is great number of illuminated
sounds is also reducing because they
changed the standards for signing or
even to have it lit now we can use
reflective materials and it doesn't need
to be lit for certain science safety
ones they're still having to be lit so
your Junctions give way will be a lit
universals
um
they've got these called CMS systems
which is basically the the system that
we'll control the large percentage of
them to 23 000 of them and Counting so
every time we put a new units in it's
going to have another one on it which
does allow us to that remote dimming
type of effect as such which is good
news
um
um
so basically the total number of um
units is now
um increasing we've now got new new to
come in one of the problems is stock
Wise from what we've got we've got
concrete we've got cast
um all at end of life
the only way to test the cat the only
way to test either then we stop visually
looking and go is it cracked you can't
hit it with a hammer because it will
break unlike the Steelers you can do for
various tests so the tests have come
through
um November some tests that come through
for this is a recent events so you can
see from there we've got 42 Reds these
are columns only this is not the
lanterns this is purely The Columns
we've got a further 119 93 I think it is
um which I also read these all have
immediate impact we have to cut them
down for safety
and we've had one unit that fell down a
10 meter unit and fortunate at Warburton
way in the countryside through the year
because of high winds
it's part of the process that we have to
worry about in the sense that we've got
assets that are
more than their life designs 25 years
um so we try out utmost to sort of keep
on top of that with a number of years we
test four thousand is structurally
tested
on top of that then I'll just tested
structurally the test is electronically
so the safety electrics the door's been
fitted right it's earth right Etc they
again end up with failures somewhere
different levels of interventions but
again they've resulted in people taking
the door off and the concrete panels
Come Away With It or they actually you
know didn't put the finger through the
bottom of it because he's rotted away at
the base
so these sort of things generate even
further um problems Falls and then we
get some from the ball clean the
condition wise where we go around
cleaning the internal alignments etc etc
um what I would say is we are driven by
Reds at the moment from we're not
investing in Anthony knew about you know
a new type of lamp and all that we're
trying to bring around standardized as
best we can standardized units to
replace what we've got you know real
mismatches different styles of Steel
work etc so that will help us going
forward from a point of stock
investment wise
um
we're actually on the we're not actually
on the line from demand as I said each
year we've ended up moving money to
China accommodate the Reds the reds are
roughly four percent on structural four
percent they've been for the last few
years this year we're at six point two
five percent
we did a baseline survey of all the
units back in 2017 and now that Baseline
feeds how many we've got to test each
year so we're not expecting next year to
be as bad because they're now checking
on what were originally greens what
we've been checking on is like how all
the ambers Etc and they've been I said
failing quite regularly last year being
a very good example where it went
heavily
um 16 000 used to be retested uh coming
up that still needs to be done
um one of the one of the biggest issues
around around streamlining obviously
it's a it's a very numerous asset at 27
000 across the uh across the across the
borough 23 000 uh being being led and
fully controllable
one of the uh one of the biggest issues
that certainly Graham is struggling with
at the moment as well is inflation
um each each
um each set when we when we um do a
structural test it's given the red Amber
green if if it falls into Amber or
double Amber then the inspection regime
gets shorter as you would expect because
because the risk profile is higher so so
realistically if we are replacing more
columns and the inflation level being as
it being as it is at this moment in time
um the inflation level on Street
lighting columns being stainless steel
is very undoubling is is high so we are
we are we are struggling with that what
we've done as a partnership is um our
street lighting manager um unless I've
uh have basically secured a good stock
going forward in advance to try and uh
to try and proof ourselves a little bit
against against inflation although
that's finite and that's all that's all
I'll say on that but we've done we've
done what we can to make sure that
pre-buying in advance is is taking is is
taken as a as a given
yeah and I won't go any further about
the entry line I think it's quite a lot
of conversation about tonight drainage
we've got 43 000 units um 443 40 000
units um and again another a number
that's increasing what we haven't got
these are these are pots in these
streets the grid that you see in the
next to the curb
we we haven't got a measure on linear
units because they've gone in over the
years we haven't got a measure on the
drainage stroke curb units so we've not
got a true fact on what we've got we
know got them out there we're collecting
the data
in time
they themselves obviously are cleaned
there's a cycle involved with the
revenue side on that but we do have
problems with the pipe networks you put
a tree next to the pipe it's going to
kill it you know we've got it all the
time we talked we took um
if we talked
um took a drain out it was the length of
the tree The Roots Italy is just in one
sort of thing very calm
um shelting up is another problem we've
just done some um some out on Western
housing
three meters of silt which is roughly
nine feet in all Imperial measurements
it literally touches on the side of the
the metal Coast
um and it's like again it's not just a
once not one manual you're talking gotta
go to this stuff
the rest of the air is probably the same
place same condition we are trying to
keep on top of it
but again it's one of them things it's
an old Network different parts some of
those brake work some of this clay
and flooding is not helping someone this
network wasn't designed to take off
flash floods someone's not working in
the sense of it's running at 25 capacity
so those sort of things all have are not
knock on effects on what we're doing
and just to yeah just to kind of like
grow on that as well
um the climate change kind of the
certainly weather that we've uh that
we've experienced
um and the climate change behind it is
is increasing
um the uh the level of
um
rain events which are uh which are which
are uh it sounds peculiar saying it in
Manchester but um but basically in terms
of in terms of the intensity of the rain
that comes along and therefore isolated
small Flooding at flooding events that
we that we've got we have the uh we have
um the two girl the empties and the
golientism as soon as we get any of
those those weather conditions are
afflict immediately onto reactive and we
and we move it one of those is actually
go on a regular basis when it's not on
those in those conditions is actually
um uh wandering around the wandering
around Trafford and actually gaining the
intelligence of uh intelligence of of
just exactly where all our Gully Bots
are and what they're doing and
representing that on GIS so our
knowledge picks up every year in terms
of in terms of what we do but it
shouldn't be said that the Aging Network
and uh and actually changing weather
conditions means that means that
basically there is a flood risk with um
uh with this going forward and uh what
we will have to do in the next year in
the next couple of years is take um he's
take a view on on how we I know we
attack that
can I just can I just ask about the tree
roots yeah that's uh clearly doing
damage
how do we locate that in terms of
um you know proactively looking at the
tree the only way to do is you lift up
the CTV CT Vape so you put a camera down
the drains the problem is That's So cost
prohibitive that's why no no local
pathology has that knowledge of its
Network
um massive Investments for the return on
it you know is you're going to be pull
this way yeah but we know where the
drains are and we know where the trees
are we know we're not sort of tests
the problem is you've got that many
trees next to that many genes and these
these these this is the a56 you know the
nearest tree of the this particularly
was
25 foot away
these you know that's the problem you're
up against you can go to Every goalie
and find an issue with a tree within 25
fourths of it so
to get into that the only way to get
into the drain is you've got to break
down the side of a particle on some of
these pots to actually get a camera
through so there's a repair and cost
involved in that as well I think chair
what the the network as it is and the
age of it
um 95 of it is within the range of the
tree
um and uh and in terms of in terms of of
us doing a CCTV camera uh camera survey
of that it's it's not really not really
well it isn't achievable in terms of its
under current budgets and probably
wouldn't be in terms of doing a risk
assessments on it to be honest
um the um the issue that we've got is
that we get repeated
um uh Gully problems and as soon as we
get a repeated one uh we keep we keep
hold of the information and then we will
have a draining supervisor visit the
visit the site if the if they call the
empty account move it after two or three
or three attempts and it's written it's
a repeat and we're not gonna get getting
massively heavy heavy um heavy weather
in a particular place then we'll revisit
it and look at what we what we actually
have to do even then
there will be blood pressures on on
doing every dig down that we uh that we
have within the within the area
um
the whole point of the high amp is
realistically not to it's almost to kind
of flag up these problems because this
is and I can't stress the deteriorating
asset um asset statement more than uh
than than I really want to
um because
um with every with every part of what
we've got by definition it's man-made
the exceptional trees
um and uh and basically it does
deteriorate and if we don't match the uh
match the uh the replacement level then
we have to manage it with the resources
we've got and uh drainage
some other questions uh yeah I think
it's three it's Jill Rose and Barry
um
yeah I was just going to ask if there's
any Focus or sustainable drainage and
light prevention such as you know the
fact that we need more permeable land
and people have you know there's any
kind of things about raising awareness
to Residents about Paving over their
front Gardens that kind of thing and
artificial Lawns because we need more
permeable land and also aware that the
leaf clearance program I've got a lot of
complaints from that as well about
because it's I mean not something
adequate is in that and that does cause
blood colors as well thank you yeah and
from a point of shorts every design
everything that comes to the table being
you development otherwise even when
we've got problems we're trying to
resolve them we will look at the option
of what can you do for a short system
you know this is becoming a big thing
and it's something that we get we aim
for getting grants off the advances
before and from the network that's all
Network we can get grants if we take on
certain things which attenuation in
basically
um in terms of the in terms of three the
three questions I think the first one in
terms of communications around around
the the implications of uh of people
changes to their property I think that's
certainly something we can look at from
a Communications point of view we don't
actually at this moment in time so
that's that's absolutely Fair uh the
second the second one
um in terms of putting in Subs on a
stick on on existing property
um the sustainable Drainage Systems
um it's it's quite it's quite difficult
in terms of in terms of the capital
investment to go in to go into those
particular areas plus there's a
maintenance responsibility around it
with new developments
um we are we are more than open to uh to
sustainable drainage I think it will
form part of the part of the design
guide that Rebecca puts together as part
of the part of the planning and I'm from
a highways Authority no issues with it
as long as we as long as we secure
maintenance funding from their from the
particular developer and from the tree
clearance point of view we've tried
something slightly different this year
in terms of the terms of uh of tree
clearance factors to concentrate
realistically on a lot of the areas with
a lot of the trees realistically and I
don't think we've managed to get it
quite right but um but in terms of the
the amount of um uh certainly the
weather conditions this year uh the um
the cold snap
um which I think everybody was
discomforted by mostly our tree stock
um they uh it fell in a very short
period of time uh across across most of
the area
um the
um the actual tree team have picked up
on unprecedented 16
um 1600 tons of uh of of leaves this
year
um so uh so it's more than more than
usual uh by by this stage I think the I
think well they were hamstring world uh
with was uh was that it was over a very
short period of time and in terms of
having the resources to cover the entire
area I'm afraid I'm afraid we haven't so
it's much nicer if it slowly gets colder
across the area
can we move on because I think we've got
quite a lot of questions and so on so on
as quickly as we can get through them uh
councilors Tom Tom
thank you for the reports um the road
drainage is becoming more and more of a
problem I can feel it in my world that
when it rains heavily odd sustained
that's when the emails start coming
about flooded roads so I'm glad it's uh
it's been looked at
and I just wanted to know a bit more
about
how we're going to collect the data
going forwards on the condition of the
roads when it rains and floods what kind
of information we're going to collect on
that and how how are we going to collect
it we're actually doing two systems at
the moment we have um the machine is
physically gone around it's working not
working type of thing it's collecting
the GPS points of these so we know where
they are and what sort of flow base we
can expect from we've got another thing
called rainmap which is something we
bought the software that basically maps
and you can almost work out where where
the flash floods are going to appear and
what um consequence Etc so you'll learn
from that there's an exercise you know
and times almost like there's a there's
a you know the workout is 150 year flood
sort of you know raise we're getting
more of those and that's what I think
we're trying to map in there's a lot of
Intelligence on trying to get its
Gathering data that we can start working
with we all know you don't cheat the the
units at the top rails the bottom of the
hill is going to cause you the problem
and that's the sort of thing we still
can't neglect at the top you've still
got a capture the top now
I I think you could um gather some
information from users as information
points because we know our worlds and we
know where the floods happen on the road
so we're happy to help out if you need
anything yeah locally councilors council
with them we'd absolutely encourage that
uh the um what I would say is that when
we do get a um a large downpour and
there was a long a last three foot
through flow of water that people wait
25 minutes for the capacity of the
capacity of the drains to take it
because I think what we do get actually
quite a few false Flags when it when it
comes to it and I do not doubt that
there are lots and lots of issues out
there as for all the reasons that we've
we've already we've already said but
actually in terms of in terms of um in
terms of just making sure the Gully
Gully flow actually happens there are
actually to be honest sticking an
umbrella down it is actually sometimes
sometimes a good idea and will so and
we'll flow it and if you and and to be
fair the uh if we if we wait an element
at a time a lot of the time the drain
the drains are this wide and a lot of
water on top just it just requires a
little bit of time to go down
uh Rose asked my first question so this
will be this will be brief the um how
does it work in terms of interaction
with the United utilities assets because
we've had one recently and it's the
third one I think in our Ward we've had
where the drainage blocked and in fact
the drain is not blocked it's United
utilities so I guess the question is how
does that interaction work do we work
with them closely do we monitor uh do we
have a way of um of flagging this with
them so it's actioned quickly we never
know how confidence we are of their
inspection regime
um
I can't comment on their their
inspection ratio that's their that's
their inspection regime uh we have a um
we have a dedicated resource in terms of
Advantage drainage engineer who uh talks
to not only United utilities but also
the environment agency to flag up any
issues that any issues that are
incumbent on them uh coming uh coming
through and any of the crossover
crossover areas
um uh which and I always dealt with one
of one of your issues so so to be fair
um he does the best to uh to try and uh
to try and make sure that United
utilities are held responsible for
anything that they're doing online
Network
United utility what's their lead time to
sort it out do we have an agreed lead
time with them or did they have an
agreed kpi as part part of the the
general work do we know no we this is
the fast Yankee facilities is a private
sector company we don't have an SLA with
him it's a big problem all authorities
have glacy Manchester have actually
um requested that Asset Management Group
have requested the
um the chair of the United utility comes
and meets people to discuss this because
it is a big problem
you asked them to do something it's not
like us we haven't got this sort of SLA
we can push upon them
um
they are to somebody quite frustrating
to work with for that and in all
honestly that's the problem they are
frustrating to work with we still have
issues you know months on that they
haven't dealt with that we're still
going back to and you know as you say
the resource is dealing with it it's
he's very good at what he does you know
he's very skilled in it and he does have
contacts within the United utilities
drivers to navigate things because we
get frustrated as do every other
authority one of the uh one of the
things that I can assure you is that we
raise it really quickly because in the
interim we take the uh we take the issue
and send our machine out to deal with
the problems so it's in our interest to
uh to Race City and attitude utilities
and get United Hills is to deal with it
um when they can I think
um
it might be useful you know progressing
that thought really in terms of
utilities maybe we could get
um you know some of their staff in
um so so that we can actually
um you know raise this whole issue with
them how they're relating to
um other zabara so that that might be an
a thing that we can do now there's three
other people
um Council yeah Council all right thanks
chair I'll let you come in Steve
um yeah I was gonna ask a general
question about the impact of climate
change and you mentioned the drainage
was the obvious one it's gonna have a
massive impact but I wondered do you
include any assumptions or modeling and
your plan going forward because it seems
to me that if you don't do that
the whole the budgets and the time
scales and what you want to achieve uh
is going to be completely not not of
course so Jamaica some some sort of
assumptions anyway
there's a tripod Group which is United
utilities
and the local Authority is greater
Manchester because he doesn't stop at
the borders you know it's it's across to
everybody so there's a party that
constantly works together on those sort
of aspects because you're right you say
making assumptions we need the evidence
of the data and we'll build an answer
collectively we work together that
relationship does work very well
because I mean the impact on climate
change isn't just going to be on the
drainage it's going to be on the roads
themselves and if essentially all part
of the infrastructure so you need to try
and make some
some guess anyway what's like going to
be likely impact of that going going
forward
in terms of the in terms of the detail
of the modeling that we do uh one of the
the advantages of using using some of
the companies that companies that we're
doing and probably the complexity of
this is that is that we're trying to use
constantly updated data sets to do it
there's one like one of the reasons why
unfortunately it was late
um but uh but but realistically the
those data sets change on a on a a very
very frequent basis uh to do to do that
so yeah we we do our best is is the
short answer to that one thank you
thank you yeah uh I think there are so
many reasons causing the blockchains uh
in my world uh leaves tend to be the big
reason they haven't been swept then they
they stay there eventually block the
trains and then you mentioned maybe
become compost and many people report it
but we hardly see any blockchains being
cleared and now as you mentioned
previously if that can be so easily just
using Umbrella
give a push if that can be done why not
you guys have a quick fix programs just
give I have this blockchain I have a
quick yeah push
unfortunately we have limited resources
it's quite a big yeah quite a big area
um to deal with
um the the problems I mentioned before
with the with the leaves was the
Nicole's Latin and cold snap this time
actually happened to the entire area at
once so uh basically the leaves dropped
across the across the area
realistically then putting uh putting a
priority level on on where we clear with
the sweepers that we've got uh to to do
um we prioritized and prioritized Areas
with heavy
um heavy coverage
um immediately it froze so uh so
basically you have a you have an element
of elements of leaves which freeze and
stick to the floor sweepers can only
deal with certain amounts so
realistically
as I said as I said before we've
actually you've actually cleared
um
1600 tons of leaves this year which is
more than we've ever share we've ever
moved in uh in certainly my my
experience uh in the in the council so
yes there are there are some quick fixes
um one thing and one thing that I I
really do think we do need to do is to
get some uh get some Communications out
to people about how they can help
themselves as well
um that realistically there are simple
fixes and if the simple fix doesn't work
then there are some there are some more
heavy heavyweight
um
things that we can do but in terms of
Machinery everybody wants them all the
time there are five small
small sweepers there are there are four
Big Macs that we bet that we hire to
especially for the uh for the for the
leaf cleaner Leaf clearance and we have
two uh drainage
um drainage golly empty machines
um they can't be everywhere
you have any statistics about how many
blockchains has been cleared in a cut in
the year yes we can and we can supply it
that would be great thank you
yeah thank you for this I was waiting to
the end so um but we seem to have gone
to questions and I wanted to discuss
things on the highway road conditions
but we've come on to drainage now we've
got um questions I would incidentally
like to support what seemed to be
cross-party comments I think the leaf
sweeping program is I'm sorry to say
being very poor actually for many years
um clearly the task at hand is one of
priorities I think this is where it gets
tricky we talked earlier about the
surface conditions of the roads uh roads
a roads B roads Etc they may appear that
way on an Ordnance survey map and it may
or may not be as important
um when you're looking at the hierarchy
but just because a road looks that way
and the database are on the map changes
in housing developments expanding
schools working practices all of these
means certain roads actually can be even
if they're mine are very important they
can be used as an arterial route even
though they're a sea Road or a u-road so
I wanted to Echo something councilor
Thompson opposite me said
to me this it feels like this is where
local councilors come in I want so my
question is question one can you tell me
to what extent the local knowledge and
the experience of the elected members
actually factors in your decision making
because we talked about the vehicles
that go out and do the inspections we
talked about the hierarchy as an a road
as a b-roll we talked about how long
it's been there I didn't hear any actual
input from the elected members
and since I might not get a chance to go
in again briefly question two well
obviously we're all familiar with this
criteria for road maintenance in terms
of pothole depth and all this stuff we
get this all the time
however I hear very little about what's
known as drivability
so there can be roads and there's many
in my ward where the individual defects
don't meet the criteria but the whole
Road surface from one end to the other
is full of multiple minor defects none
of which meet the criteria but it means
what traditionally in highways used to
be known as the drivability is extremely
poor how do we progress that if
individual defects don't meet the
criteria thank you
in terms of the year in terms of the um
of the first question around uh sorry
just can I go could you could you just
repeat the repeat the first part
in very brief summary to what extent do
the views and the experiences of elected
members feature in your factoring for
just deciding on what roads to to look
at the um the answer to that question
was was right at the beginning of the um
beginning of the of the presentation
um the high amp is a statement of fact
so uh so realistically it's based around
uh based around DFT and it's based
around that based around uh central
government kind of uh kind of figures
with intervention levels which we agree
with TFG tfgm level to cross-creator
Manchester so uh so realistically we
need to look at it from a um an
engineering point of view first and
foremost at the end of the at the end of
that particular that particular period
then then basically the government and
the um the the elected members view will
be taken but we have to come at it from
an engineering point of view with a
level of uh with a set of metrics which
can be proved objectively and those we
take from the DFT
um from um I'm from
um and from uh on a regional level gym
on that this is a very clinical sort of
um
engineering skill set we do take
accountant Council we do have a
mechanism that takes that on board the
problem we've got is you end up looking
at the engineering aspects and you can't
check every single every single Road in
there so you end up with a top one with
you starting to work on WE factored in
council's complaints but the thing about
it is we score that as a one because we
know you you know it's an issue for
yourselves as the resident we take
accounts of when residents complain as
well as as much as we do the
um the councils so that is actually
factored in as part of the fine tuning
that comes at the at the end of all this
what we've gone through impact and uh
you know utility issues etc etc we do
take a ball and take on board that has
both
um so in terms of that is objectivity I
think I think first of all is the is the
major is the major issue and so does the
second question in terms of drivability
um I wish we're in that luxury uh to be
honest to to get to open to get to a
point where we're looking at that we're
looking at Major defects first and
foremost our first our first Port of
Call with that I think we I think we
showed them that with the graph of uh of
where we've actually put money into the
uh put money into the micro Asphalt in
for four or five years we were dealing
with A's B's and C networks the reason
for that was safety so the first the
first the first intervention that we
will make every single time will be
where we see there is a safety issue and
uh and that uh that is the the part of
it when we get to a stage where we've
got the excess money to be able to uh to
be able to deal with uh deal with minor
defects then I will take your point we
will we will most certainly look at
drivability but the um what um but our
first our first and foremost uh foremost
responsibilities got into the driving
public
counselves
yeah
yeah
a good point just on the on the gullies
and street cleaning and that is what I
wanted to comment on a particular in the
role as an except member yeah when I
first took on the role one of the first
things actually asked was for mapping
exercise of all the gullies uh where
they are the numbers and the different
types and uh and obviously given the
nature of Trafford obviously it was to
to former counties Langston Cheshire
edition satinum of individual
authorities and many houses over many
different years there's many different
types in different locations so it's all
okay simple one machine can fix it in
some cases you can get some that needs a
different type of equipment to actually
clean the goals out as well as that
complicates but we have that sort of
picture now which is really helpful in
that sense of it so I think that that's
a positive there uh no no then just uh
on Leaf Craven's work there obviously at
the end of each year uh season that it
is reviewed and can be improved
obviously I think we welcome input from
a member particularly in some cases
obviously when these four it's beyond
air control it's obviously in hands of
God in that sense of it uh and and that
they'll tell them when they fall down
and they do I've seen at least start to
fall as early as August and as late as
they were this year I think in case in
in some Wars a particularly Norful pair
of India particularly where the most
Urban and the warmest the least stayed
onto the longest I think it's well well
into the uh to November before they
started falling off which is the latest
I haven't known it and of course that
coincided with the storms I think last
year we had a real good positive
feedback it went really well I think
this year hasn't I think we need to do
look at that as well but the rather a
lot of issues around how that affects it
yes I mean we can go we all can go along
on the street and we can see it's
flooding we see something blocking us
from leaps you'd actually just move it
away before or get a garden can do
absolutely would uh if that helps it
doesn't help it and obviously it is
report put into actually investigated
but I think one of the things that I've
noticed one of the things I've had
discuss with later on when I've been to
discuss the team was actually as we move
forward with climate change we are going
to get getting much more rain on more
frequent bases at some times here
obviously we might have more gaps
between more sort of hot weather in the
sense in the winter we're going to get
more milder and more sort of rainy
weather so we do need to look at how we
can actually best tackle this and
obviously view some scrutiny and other
members would actually be really welcome
in that Center I thought really would
appease uh it's one of the things that
men could look at and actually how we do
that certainly a Dev important area to
me and I think we need to actually look
at is there ways we can improve it
obviously if we had funding absolutely
like a it's an area I'd like to see a
lot more investment put into it
particularly but it's an area that's
going to be an issue over the coming
years obviously we have an aging
Victorian system in place and we cannot
just it cannot just simply be replaced
obviously there are issues across the
network with different types of problems
in that sense of it and and it's nearly
that we need we need to look at I'd like
to see uh really that investment if we
can and obviously if we can get more
money if we put one of my number one
priority will be to actually look at
that particularly there it as with
climate change it will actually mean
that we'll get more on a frequent basic
and like I said last few nights for
instance it it's built up quite heavily
overnight and it'll take some hours for
it to go down so some people look out in
a lot I think oh it's flooded uh the
first thing to think oh if they clean
the goalie that'll solve it and that
isn't always the case because sometimes
it's the amount of rain coming in a
short period that means that that has a
system can't cope initially so it needs
time to go down I think probably need to
actually work on the messaging how that
comes out to people to actually
understand isn't just a case of Simply
uh a bit more improving the uh the
cleaning system actually helping some
cases it won't and it's something that
we may have to live with in that sense
of it maybe something that even more
resources it wouldn't solve the problem
in some locations because it's simply
the sheer volume particularly in the
summer when we get that really that
heavy when he gets we can get as much
rain falling in two hours as you can in
a couple of weeks or more yeah so we
need to yeah okay but that's basically
what I want to say chair but yeah so
leave that particularly but it is an
area that's priority thank you thank you
um is there any other issue I I know I'm
conscious that we haven't quite finished
the presentation so are we going to Wick
through that we could win that fairly
quickly don't worry yeah yeah okay all
right moving on um instructors we've got
I think see there's a number 178
structures in in our gross value 358
million so we've got those numbers we do
Channel inspections we do principal
inspections there's an explanation in
the notes you've got but sort of
explains the variations in them
um and then we do special inspections
which is basically a consequence of an
impact Etc
um which come along bridges are based on
what they call a beside condition
industry so that's that's that one in
the sense that every bridge is inspected
over a period of time
this is a a good Bridge so there's a a
gauging of what the structure should be
the concerns the average the expectation
each Bridge it builds up what as you can
appreciate of and a number of elements
everyone on elements is assessed
separately to get this score so it's not
just the concrete it's the concrete and
the steel and the lighting units and the
support beams and anything else that's
associated with Evan was assessed
this goes onto a system called pontus
another electronic system which gives us
more data
um I'm not put the full length on that
but this is an outcome of investment
potential that we could do at the moment
on the value of the assets so basically
over the 30-year period after 159 58
million pounds worth of work
he's going to be broken down you can
invest and this is one example a heavy
investment for the start
you'll see a deterioration but you'll
also see an increase on the on the
issues for the investment will improve
for the constant investment we don't
invest heavily in structures against
another one that is well under invested
in unfortunately
um we are dealing with things I mean a
good example is we are now dealing with
Scout onto the stone bridge near tgis
which is part of the river amazing
common problem scattered on Bridges
something that people don't see but it's
something we have to deal with it's one
of these um the the issue issue with
structures is
of the uh of the 60 odd
um kind of Road bridges that we've got
some of them are in extremely critical
economic economic locations and can and
can cause uh and obviously any failure
in those particular particular ones will
cause and cause big economic issues to
the uh
um so therefore we do keep uh keep a
very close eye on them
um but they they are risky structures at
the end of the end of the day we have we
have a um an investment uh or we have a
a risk assessed amount of amount of
money that we spend on it
um as Liza said we could spend a lot
more
no
uh broken signs um we know we've got
1100
um non-illuminated sounds these are
complete chef and those are illuminators
again the inspectors are picking these
up as you walk around you'll see signs
the posts have rotted the signs are
fading out
another area where we're having on the
invest invest as well
um there's
the
there's been a a recent change in
standards so um some of the units you
know are now increasing in the
non-illuminators because we're taking
out the illuminators
but again something that year on year
heavily under invested 100 Grand top
sliced out of wedges
landscape um very briefly on this this
is one we've got assets again so one of
the big problems and one of the
complaints we do get is grass verges
parking on grass verges
there's no one solution to that because
you've got it's an education thing
you've got either got a football odds in
at Cost that's our main states or you
put soil back in and that's not going to
stop people doing it
we've had trees and we've unfortunately
about that recently with highways to use
that'll come down there's a regime the
traffic officers to look after the trees
still
um they have a regular inspection on
that as well but again it's a low budget
um item that we've got and it's
something that you know it exists on the
highway
summary of it
um so you can see those figures on
um we've got a number of elements of
where we are investing so the column
um which is in there which states we're
off with three to four million pound a
year on roads
um that actually is quite various in
that
um foot weighs 300 000 but alien arms
talking about 1.7 million pound required
for studies days over 10 years
um world also have this there's a caveat
on that that the top one we've talked
about roads we end up taking one hour
roads to facilitate the other part of
the works
um so all the fencing barriers come out
of that the foot waves are coming out of
that we supplement lighting out of that
with Superman structures structures team
out of that so it doesn't have an impact
on what is a natural investment in
carriageway becomes an investment in The
Wider asset to to summarize it as we're
a bit short of time
um yeah it's in blue at the bottom we
will we will we will send it across
currently we've got a 4.2 million pounds
a million pounds budget to to look after
the asset
to maintain steady state we would need a
further 11.
so that gives you a give you when when
we talk about deteriorating assets we're
talking about deteriorating asset yes
it's from a very big total in terms of
the terms of uh of the the initial uh
the initial uh 1.6 billion uh worth of
the uh uh worth of the asset but that's
um but effectively when we when we we do
hear about potholes and so on and so
forth that direct effect into potholes
is direct effect into drainage issues
and some Direct effects into into those
Revenue things that people want to want
to fix on a regular basis and um the
issue realistically is not a Trafford
issue I would just like to say that it
is a national issue we
I thought this is what what does this
mean uh we're holding the line when it
comes to the uh when it comes to the
revenue uh budget that we've got
um we will not be perfect in terms of in
terms of
um uh meeting uh meeting everything
currently we are meeting all of our
parameters around defects for the uh for
the for the roads
um and we will continue to hold that
line in the next in the next couple of
years
um realistically though we know that we
are up against some very
um needy parts of the council as well in
terms of in terms of budget um uh in
terms of budgets uh budget division
um realistically that's not the job of
this in terms of uh in terms of the
higher the high amp is just to State the
fact that uh that effectively that asset
is deteriorating at more than 10 million
pounds per year across structures roads
uh roads footways fortways drainage
Street lighting and so and so on it's a
fairly big area but it's the biggest
it's the biggest asset that the council
currently owns
um in terms of what we do about it we're
taking advantage of every uh amount of
additional funding that we can get from
tfgm from central government
environmental funding I've put the last
the last comment on or rather Leslie did
it for me which is none of this is
assured and none of this is consistent
so so that is a changeable Feast on a
year-by-year basis so so realistically
while we've been uh while crsts is
welcome because it because it fixes it
fixes a period of a period of time for
us to uh for us to plan properly that's
not been the case in the case in the
previous years and in terms of pothole
funding just to use it just to use a
small uh small example which will not be
a small example because it paid for
quite a lot of quite a lot of parcels
across the business uh across the uh
across the uh the area uh that possibly
is not available so uh so so
realistically
we a are not the only the only borrower
that I feel uh that are failing this
feeling the squeeze every single Borough
in the country is and uh and
realistically what we've got to do is is
work with the assets that we're given
and work with the money that we're given
to uh to get the best out of it which is
what we try and do
okay I I know councilor Ross wanted to
come in sorry I'm I'm not abusing my
position here I hope I was just you
answered my question at the uh the very
last slide about it being a a national
problem
um and of course it is and obviously
what I'll take away from what has been a
very interesting presentation that I've
relearned a lot and picked up on some
new stuff on is that we obviously need
to do some cross-council work to Lobby
the government because yeah there's the
the the infrastructure across the the
country will be similar ages and will
have those concerns so yeah I'm glad I
stayed for this because um yeah I've
picked up another action so thank you
Chris
is there any more questions
yeah
Geraldine
thank you that uh as as something very
interesting I have learned learned some
things tonight
um I had three different things I wanted
to ask about
um
cycleways I see that we don't know how
long our segregated cycleways are
um the bad news is that they're not very
long but the good news is they wouldn't
take very long to count so I wonder if
we can if we can get that that data or
why we don't have it already
um uh one of the things mentioned here
of course
um was pedestrian barriers which we have
quite a lot of
um but a lot of people are starting to
think that actually pedestrian barriers
are part of the problem rather than part
of the solution to road safety and
wondering if there's any consideration
being given into putting in fewer of
them or ideally taking them out and the
problems of course are that in the event
of a crash or anything going wrong on
the road that actually trap for
pedestrians people on bikes and people
on motability scooters
um are trapped between the barrier and
the car and they're implicated in a lot
of crashes like that they also create a
visual barrier so the drivers can't see
what's going on in the pavement as well
and but actually crucially if huge
impact they have as they create
Severance lines in communities and so
reduce active transport a classic
example is if you any of you try to get
from Stratford Library to Stratford Mall
without using steps there's the tunnel
that's tunnel has got steps and it's
it's probably 10 minutes and it's it's
literally just right there
um so these barriers are actually you
know it seems causing more problems than
they they are solving really
um and then finally
um I noticed this um carbon reduction
was mentioned in the section on LEDs but
actually
are roads foot ways and cycleways are
where a huge amount of our carbon
emissions are coming from and mostly the
roads and rather than the footways of
the cycleways and so I was interested
that that wasn't really mentioned here
as mentioned it threw away comment about
it being a a challenge for the future
um so I suppose I'm just wondering how
big their features in your thinking in
in your department or if it's more a
question perhaps for the executive
members
um are we joined up here are we are we
putting these these two things together
because if this is one of our biggest
assets even if our roads produce no
carbon from cars and even are we looking
at the materials that are used in things
like that the embedded missions so thank
you
um
I'll do my best there's the as ever in
terms of the I think um you're
absolutely right we uh we haven't
probably got an accurate count of the
segregate cycleways and realistically we
showed us is not very much
um I am hopeful that that will be a lot
more
um when we come and present this uh
present this High amp where I am next
year
um we we are pursuing several
um
uh several projects in the area around
the a56 to make what we've got more
permanent to uh to actually give
segregated production protection for uh
for cyclists
um in continuous Roots as much as we
possibly possibly can into Manchester
the um in terms of the pub barrier I
agree
um I think yeah I think in terms of uh
in terms of that we've got a
decluttering uh process which is which
is happening at the moment
um it will not clear every piece of per
piece of pedestrian Marion barrier said
we've got to do a risk assessment on on
each one and take it back case by case
basis what I can tell you is in terms of
new designs for um uh for looking at
some of the key routes around site
around cycling uh in terms of in terms
of how the implication of LTM 120 but
also in terms of the widest widest game
we are looking at it very seriously at
ped barriers to whether it's uh whether
it's actually doing the job it needs to
however having said that I have to be
balanced in certain areas where they re
where where you have
um yeah pedestrians and you have and you
have a stream of stream of traffic
coming out of a um or stream of
pedestrian traffic coming out of coming
out of an access and having some some
barrier in the way in the way the road
is probably needed in those places but
again we pull that through a risk
assessment
in terms in terms of carbon carbon
reduction in terms of in terms of carbon
count we are working kind of to uh to
look at uh to look at Carbon countless
powerful right part of our overarching
high-end but one of the things that we
are we um we absolutely have to do now
and rightly so is is do a carbon count
in any of the new projects that we that
we do so uh so any of the um any of the
projects that we uh that we go into uh
go into will be it will be subject to uh
subject to measurement for uh for carbon
the um what I can tell you in terms of
in terms of the the projects that we've
done this year
um the glad to know the micro asphalt is
probably the least of of the of the
options that we could do on a car but on
a carbon point of view so in terms of of
getting the amount of amount of area
that we that we do for uh for the least
amount of carbon place carbon placed
into the into the atmosphere and into
the environment
um the um the micro Rush felt in the
Australian that we've done is is far in
advance and we can give you some
information on that
can you start to that as part of we are
reporting regular front carbon we've
invested in carbon model systems Etc
we've actually been sent out to The
Wider Community to emphasize what's
worth what's what it's about you tell
the wise yeah now we've been looking for
carbon reducing materials and one spills
on the show you know six months later
it'll be another product we will try it
to reduce the cost there's a lot of
materials that we use now are a lot
better normal materials we avoid
anything
you know so uh yes it's very much
okay
um I think we've uh asked the questions
as we've gone along
um I would like to thank you for quite a
comprehensive
um
discussion and presentation and around
the highway infrastructure
um which is very important to all of our
residents and I think it's very
important to all the members of this
Council
and clearly
I think
um probably across the country that
um the infrastructure is in deep decline
um and I think that is because it's
under investment quite frankly
um but I think Alex would have picked up
a lot of the issues that have been
raised at this meeting by the members
and we will feed that in in into this
committee and probably to the executive
and
um
clearly
getting the the the the highway
infrastructure uh up to a level that we
would like would cost absolutely
millions that we don't have so we do
have to manage it in the best way that
we
you know we possibly can
um and no one's saying that is easy he
did a very difficult job but we thank
you for for the presentations
um yeah Alex you just wanted uh sorry
could I just swallow you up very good uh
summarization just by asking one last
question I think it'll help Council Ross
and what he's trying to do around
logging is uh you gather all the data
about the the asset itself is much data
gathered around like the costs of this
deteriorating asset how much it's
costing the Trafford economy and when
it's going to go along the um
deterioration that you're recording and
the
um assumptions of how it's going to go
when it's going to start costing
um like actual Public Safety and all
those things like how many years have we
got left before like people's lives are
starting to be quite at risk from the
deterioration of the roads and
Etc
foreign
great question one of the one of the um
one of the issues with even getting the
report is that this is a really movie
it's a moving face it is a it is
influenced by so many things uh from
from usage
um usage of cars for instance there was
um during the pandemic less cars were
used less uh less roads were uh less
roads were used uh in terms of in terms
of that and that had earned and that had
an effect on on what the what the um
what what the computer system uh uh put
out
in terms of the effects of when when the
Tipping Point is
um into in terms of that certainly the
certainly the data is there to uh to
look at uh look at when we start to um
to have a revenue cost which which goes
which goes up and and that can be
supplied in terms of economic cost
any thoughts yeah well one thing you do
is hold one's account you turn part of
that is your gross replacement so you
know you start from slash
DRC depreciation is also recorded So
part of a whole last survey Network
tells how much on what rates our asset
is failing to a monetary value
how you then take that and say where's
the Tipping Point and what's the
correlation that I'm trying to probably
got that as you look on it one access at
a time
collectively pulling that together
will take a bit longer
and having all that things you know
we're requesting days of both values
there's always something that comes into
it we never knew out and talks never put
in place you could not lose it's ever
been recorded what's gone in development
has existed for years it's been ad hoc
work it's gone on in school
about getting that thanks advice we've
got a good handle on it we know that
that multi value is
what we can't say is at which point it
becomes activity
um if one of the structures falls down
that Tipping Point will be immediate you
know so uh someone's on to to be to be
fair it will be lesser uncertain of the
units and the other the other things but
we are cognizant of the fact that
certainly the increase in risk of floods
and the increasing risk of uh of that is
having an effect now so uh so what so
what we what we are trying to do is to
make sure that our um our budget is
going forward address those issues and
for instance one of the one of the keys
uh this time that was in that was in the
presentation was around how much uh how
how much we've put onto Street lighting
and while we do have certain Savings in
Savings in those uh in those that only
involves turning the light off on voice
and the actual structure remains and we
have a responsibility to make sure that
those structures stay perpendicular
um because otherwise they are a uh
they're a they're a safety risk so as I
as I said to one of the answers and uh
answers um a little bit earlier on what
we are trying to do is to address safety
issues first to format so that will be
always the priority a priority of the
decisions that we take from an objective
point of view
no no you you of course can can go if
you so please yeah yeah
um so we're on item uh six electric
vehicle charging strategy
so uh I think Aiden's going to
thank you chairman thank you for the
invitation to join scrutiny committee
again it's nice to be with you a third
time on the chart now I think so you're
getting your money through that with me
now
now I'm conscious that the report that's
been circulated is more so
um a collection of slides from a
PowerPoint presentation than a sort of
written paper the information contained
in the report is to my mind pretty
self-explanatory with the presentation
detailing work that has been undertaken
to install electric vehicle charging
points to date
um I'm a future ambition to expand that
work
um potential alternative provision for
electric vehicle charging and also um an
assessment of the challenges that are
faced in attempting to build an electric
vehicle and charging infrastructure
across the buffer
um so the slides have been circulated
earlier today and hopefully have been
seen and digested by members so I'm
wondering whether there's an appetite
for us to run through the presentation
I'm sure Shaman would happily oblige if
so or if people have already sort of can
um understood the information that's
been circulated happy to proceed
straight discussion or questions I'm
more than happy to defer to the
preference of committee chair so I'll
I'll leave that with you
how do you enough chance to read it yeah
uh
so are there any questions
yeah
councilor Carter accounts were
here
thanks chair and uh thanks
um Aiden for giving us those two options
as well
um
confess I've got a real real bug bear on
one of the points in this so thanks
really really interesting information we
know
that the demand for electric charge
Vehicles is going to go up in part
because in a foreseeable time frame
you're not going to be able to buy
internal combustion engine vehicle so we
know there's going to be a dramatic
demand and you quite eloquently or the
slides around quite Alec only points out
that we're going as fast as we can and
there are limits to how many public
places you can charge vehicles
there's a thing in here that says
something about and we aim to have you
know people everybody within 10 minutes
of a public charging point for somebody
whose normal processes drive onto a
petrol station fill up for 40 seconds
drive off
a 20-minute drive a return drive and
potentially a 30 to 60 Minute dwell time
whilst you're waiting for your turn and
then five to ten minutes to charge your
car it's simply not something that is
practical
um so in relation to charging outside of
your home if you're privileged enough to
live in a home with a drive well
if you can afford an electric car you
can afford an electric charger on your
wall and get it done for people who
don't have
off-street parking there's kind of three
options put in here and it looks like
the third one curbside charging points
in my interpretation of this is the
preferred one but it also says it costs
a fortune we ain't got any money so it's
not an option so the other two options
are have something that covers
a raised
line or dig into the pavement in order
to have a covered line there are
interesting reasons why they're not
might not be ideal but we need to find
the solutions that make them world-class
the best possible solution I don't
believe it's not possible to find
something to cover a
why that was that big
um if we look hard enough and I don't
believe every single pavement you
couldn't cut into at the residence
expense if they want to do it just like
Drop code points but they seem to be the
two options for people who haven't got
drives and the tenor of this
presentation suggests that they might be
good but we're going to dismiss them for
whatever reasons and I would request and
urge that we go back and look at what
the solutions to those are rather than
suggest that we might be able to dismiss
them thanks
I think in response to that you're quite
right there's going to be that demand
and people will want to do it anyway I
think if we had to look at what of the
better better of the two options I think
digging up a footwear is probably
something that we couldn't actually do
mainly because of the statue Undertakers
that are actually in the footways as
well so if there's lots of cross
channels
and you've got lots of gas Mains and
electricity connections and water
connections underneath the Footwear
those will compromise access for the
utility companies so that's the main
prohibitor really
um in that respect in terms of the
temporary solutions you're right there
are a lot more out there and while I was
doing the research for this there's more
and more actually coming through through
that mechanism so I think there is an
appetite now when you look at what the
temporary solutions need to be but I
think
we need to be careful where we allowed
that to happen because it can impact on
disability disability and access so we
do need to be careful about what we can
approve but I don't think it's it's off
the table
I think the other thing I would say in
terms of countries that you know I I
live in Stratford on a service street
with on the street parking that option
that people are already resorting to
around having the cable come from their
property putting over a guard over the
payment people are already doing that so
I'd say this is something that we're
we're sort of starting to learn about as
it progresses
um the other thing I would say I think I
suppose I slightly disagree with your
initial observation I think there will
need to be a bit of behavior change if
people are going to meaningfully make
um electric vehicles work
um as part of a contribution to carbon
reduction I think there will need to be
a bit of oh well you know it's not going
to be as quick as filling up a petrol
car and I'm just going to have to build
that into my routine now and I think the
exciting thing for us is that the
provision we've installed today has just
been the pretty standard charging and
you'll see from the slides that the
future ambition involves Ultra fast
charging and I think as that comes on
board people will maybe think
differently well I think this is an
emerging picture really If we're honest
about it thank you I think um we're kind
of in the beta Max versus VHS issue as
well I think there's quite a few issues
around it we're working in um looking
into the fortways we just uh We've
obviously spent quite a lot of time
talking about maintenance budgets around
around fortways uh carriageways to Seoul
um in terms of uh pertin in terms of
permanent Solutions most people have
actually asked to come that can they uh
can they put there's an element in the
presentation about putting a trench
which is effectively an akel drain um
but without any water in it
um hopefully to uh to have uh to have it
to have a cable uh there are quite a few
issues around Macy's responsibility that
um because even if the uh even if they
were fitted privately they would be
subject to subject to our Macy's regime
so the content that comes with the
maintenance cost
um plus it also also adds up to a an
issue around uh whether the parking
parking space outside the particular
house is therefore owned by the by the
particular person in that uh in that
house and realistically apart from
disabled areas that is that is not
something that's uh something that we do
within uh within within those areas we
also hit um our legalities issue around
around putting putting cables across the
uh across uh payments due to due to the
fact that people leave them so I think
one of the arguments was well what's the
difference for me hoovering the car for
instance well the fact is you don't
normally leave the Hoover Uh for uh for
eight hours
um in the car well I hope you don't
um and um unrealistically you are going
to leave that and it's going to be out
of supervision uh and crossing the
crossing and crossing the Fort Wayne so
there are some there are some challenges
I'm not going to say that they're all
off the table
um but uh but realistically when we talk
about the behavioral change
um and councilor Williams mentioned
mentioned around around the issues
around and the issues with uh moving
forward on uh moving forward on on time
scales of actually charging one of the
uh one of the biggest things that that
we do need to look at is the super fast
charging because
uh it realistically is in the future
certainly two to three years in the
future
um the analogy that I would use is uh is
an electric car uh something you um you
equate to your current vehicle or is it
something you equate to your mobile
phone your mobile phone you may charge
by your bed
um but overnight you wouldn't think of
doing that with your car and uh and and
realistically there is uh there's a
question to be to be asked about local
authorities uh local authorities
um uh participation in in what is going
to be an increase in the commercial
business uh moving forward to moving
forward to change that and uh one of one
of the elements of recommendation is
that realistically we should be looking
that we should be looking at making sure
that the
um the areas of society that are not
going to be covered by those commercial
opportunities are actually uh are
actually looked at and that's one for
one thing that we will be looking at and
I know that tfgm are also going to be
looking at
thank you if I could just ask perhaps in
12 months time if the option one of the
on on on street parking raised cover it
up thing even 12 months time we could
have what the council's view is of this
is the in the whole world of engineering
what the best solution is because I
could come up with something so not not
tomorrow but in 12 months time that'd be
really helpful
I think
um yeah so this is a whole new area for
me so I don't really understand it but I
I understand what you're saying about
how important it is that we provide
charging points in areas that are not
um run by private companies but I don't
really understand
are we getting revenue from these or is
is it what what why would people use a
Trafford one rather than a private one
was my question and also around the
rapid charges I don't know whether
they're suitable for all cars so I don't
really know enough about that and I also
think that
I I understand it does seem more
practical that people can do it outside
their homes and is there possible for
like to have one in each street so that
people can club together and and share
it and and is that a possible option as
well and I'm not I'm not entirely
convinced that
the the that there'll be more and more
electric cars being built because I
think we still need to be focusing on
public transport and
they're just so expensive and I don't
you know according to the latest
um
census statistics I think 19 of
households and traffic don't even have
cars now so
yeah it's just like I've just got loads
of questions so and I'm really
interested in learning more but I just
don't really
understand the whole thing basically but
so that was it thank you
um I think well
the answer is I don't think you're alone
um I think it's a very I think it's a
very Movable Feast at this moment in
time
um I use the beta Max for VHS VHS
um uh analogy I think it's more uh that
plus
um streaming plus
um mini disks plus everything else to be
perfectly unless there are five or six
different uh different connectors for uh
on probably more than that actually
nowadays for uh for different for a
different cars so we try to we tried to
put the ones that are the most common
out there to try and to try and give a
start and I think I think we we are
waiting for a report from tfgm that they
commissioned with Grant Thornton to see
what that says about the role of what
they perceive the low the role of local
local authorities would be in this and I
think that will that will help I'll give
us an element of the steer
um and also some funding uh some funding
that uh that will be connected to that
we have included in in this in terms of
in terms of your idea around sharing in
in areas we have included included the
um the Gable ends if you if you like I
think is probably the the the colloquial
term that we would use to try and get
away from the it's my parking parking
Bay
um so we're so realistically where we
can uh where we can put some of those in
that will probably be our next kind of
uh kind of look with our with our um uh
with our partner Bev
um
saying that level in terms of the in
terms of
the other part of uh part of you your
point around uh moving towards public
transport this is a small part of what
we've got to do and uh and for me this
is It's All About a a combined strategy
to make sure that we um we move forward
and take that Council uh that Council
priority The Greener area
um it's not going to be the complete
answer in terms of in terms of uh
electric vehicles what we are trying to
trying to do is to to make sure that
we're balancing our time between that
active travel and supporting our tfgm
partners in terms of the Metrolink and
the bus reforms that are that are going
on so there's quite a few conversations
at conversations around that I would say
that to be honest one of the uh one of
the the points that was raised uh was
raised by councilor Carter which was
around uh trying our endeavoring to get
as many people within within uh 10
minutes as possible
it is difficult uh the two major the two
major issues that are that are in this
presentation that we've uh We've we've
come across our land ownership uh which
is uh which is huge but the biggest one
is power and our power infrastructure in
this country is is
questionable as to whether it can
support uh certainly the certainly some
of the EV charging Ambitions that uh
that we would want so uh so
realistically there is there is some
pressure that needs to be put on our um
our Network colleagues um within the uh
within the electricity sector
um and I'm sure that that's been taken
up at Central central government but um
but we have found it quite difficult to
uh to locate areas with um with
sufficient
um sufficient power to do that and
that's why uh we shoot another another
paper from the first one which actually
changed some of the locations so our um
our intention of getting it within 10
minutes is is an over one whether
whether the the electricity
um uh the the electricity infrastructure
underneath supports that is another
question
I think I'll just answer your question
about Revenue as well because I think
that there's a potential missed
opportunity if we didn't go down this
road so we we've we've done a direct
partnership with buvbv with GM's partner
so we've directly engaged with them so
that we can accelerate our program so
that's why we're a little bit ahead of
the game with some of our car parks and
and the like but ideally we want to get
on streets I think we recognize we're
going to do some on street and also
those hard to reach areas where we know
we're not able to get to but equally
there's some investment opportunities I
think for some of our own land here to
give us a revenue return on that
investment so that is still an
opportunity we want to explore
okay
um thanks for that I I do recognize the
difficulties of of this particularly on
the terrorist house uh role which I
actually live on like uh councilor
Williams and it's difficult enough to to
get a parking space uh on on the road
um
but but
I I would say all sorts of different
problems uh could
um you know
could could foresee really in terms of
individual
residents in houses just putting their
own wire you know across the pavement
and uh and a whole host of people doing
the same same thing I think
um but I do like the kind of idea around
maybe one or two on on a street
depending on the length of the street
where you could actually
um you know get people to pay for for
those and
club together really
as a few residents and I know that that
is fraught with difficulties
um but
um you know we have to find some
solutions I think otherwise there'll be
a whole host of people who won't be able
to
um you know operate an electric vehicle
if we don't come up with Solutions which
we're expected to come up with Solutions
and so I know Jed's very keen around
this issue
um and and rightly so and uh and I think
he's right you know come next year
hopefully there will be a lot more
um you know points of where you can
actually
put in terms of charging of your car
because it it's a complete moving Feast
as far as I can see and all sorts can
happen in a year can't it
so thanks very much
oh sorry about yeah
yeah yeah I know I didn't I didn't see
you before right right yeah whoever is
first
I didn't see you put your hand up sorry
sorry chair
um I'll try and be brief I noticed from
the report they were initially about 60
sites but only a small fraction of
progressed I'd like to understand a
little bit more about how the locations
for those sites were chosen and whether
it was on convenience of installation or
need because when I talk to Residents
who own electric vehicles I'm not lucky
enough to do that I'm told there's
actually they feel there isn't a lot of
point in having
um having these stations in an area
where you've got a high density of
electric vehicle owners because they
tell me they like to charge them at home
so having a station five minutes away
isn't as useful because you want a
publicly available electric charging
point in the parts of the borough that
are furthest from the highest density of
ownership
um and furthermore our second point is
for those without driveways I really do
think the lamp post charging solution
like they've got in London would be the
best solution for so many reasons so I
was a bit concerned earlier when my
colleague next to me mentioned Lamppost
solution seemed a bit difficult
that then appeared to be the settled
view there is there any ambition to
actually tackle that because I think
that would be far more useful than any
of the other Solutions we've got I know
it presents challenges but I think it's
it's one that we should try and rise to
I think councilor did the point about
um
choosing locations for Council owned
electric vehicle charging points um was
sort of touched on previously in
Wisconsin a different question which is
that the ambition moving forward will be
that we will plug gaps in the provision
um which is not provided by the private
sector and where
um home ownership just isn't really
filling
um the the the provision either in terms
of the lamp post my understanding was
that they don't have the capacity to
support it because of the electrical
infrastructure but I'll defer to
um obviously stuff
um well in the first paper that we put
into put in about the EVP EV we had an
intention in terms of location to uh to
look at um the the equivalent of the
dinner plate solution around five five
minutes away or five minutes away from
uh from each of the areas without it I
think we used a um a satellite company
to look at uh look at basically locating
them
um with um with a five to five to ten
minute walking distance from uh from
most of uh from most of the houses
without out a um without a drive so that
was the first intention unfortunately
intentions don't really work with the
power system that we've got and um and
we've had to had to uh to revise that to
uh to basically look at look at
locations which crossover between
between the actual ability to put them
in
um because we do want to get a critical
massive uh massive vehicles or critical
mass of vehicle points for vehicles to
use
in terms of your point about being as
far away from the the areas of the areas
as possible I think um I think the the
average the average range of uh range of
electric cars currently 300 miles
um so it's a realistic thing with it
within that there is uh within the with
this the scope with with the borough
traffic it's quite hard to kind of kind
of obviously obviously put that put that
around and we were realistically looking
at trying to make sure that those people
who physically couldn't
um couldn't um couldn't charge them on
their Drive actually had some facility
to do so which I think will be carried
on in the policy in the policy of trying
to uh of trying to serve those uh those
areas that um that basically the private
sector will probably not invest in
um which is uh which which is an issue
um in terms of lampposts um showing us a
little bit more about it than me but one
of the one of the issues is in terms of
in terms of actually obviously some of
the current that's through the uh
through the Lamppost
do you want to say that yeah
unfortunately yeah we've got power
supply issues with our own lamp
standards as well and obviously
referring back to the high amp a lot of
our columns are not in the best of
conditions being honest it needs
investment in that asset as well so
there's an element of needing to invest
in the lamp column as well as putting a
charger and it isn't just a plug and
play solution which which would be nice
but we haven't got that but we are
trying to look for some trial sites so
it's not totally off the table we are
looking at some trial sites we've we've
we've added we've had a look at all the
other areas that have done that it does
seem to be an easier and easier solution
for uh for Town centers but the the
initial assets to be in the right
condition for us to everyone to be able
to do it
okay yeah councilor Coggins thank you
and thank you for um discussing this
item I was one of the people who
suggested we bring this to scrutiny so
I'm glad to see it here
um
the number of points um I I've first of
all the the story in in this document
starts in um 2020 but in fact the story
starts long before that I I I I Googled
in my research for this
um and in 2019 we we had an uh I was in
Altrincham today talking about the lack
of electric charging points and in fact
at that point region Road car park had
just been closed and if you read the
article it says that you know because
cancel's got these plans there'll
probably be a three-month Gap when we
don't have those um charging points in
Regent Road car park and so here we are
three years two and a half years on
still without the charging points in
Region Road car park and in fact there
is nothing in this report saying that
that has does not yet been signed as the
latest
um the latest we can hear
um so I'm really glad to see Balmoral
Road on there which I've been pushing
for for some time the causeway and
several others but um yeah there's only
really a part of the story in here and
so first of all like a little update on
what is going on with Regent Road are we
hoping to sign that very soon
I think just on Regent Road it's the the
charges are not the issue I think
there's a bigger issue with the hand
over the car park if I'm honest there's
a lot more issues within the car park
with lifts and and spaces and
availability but but the charges are not
an issue that as soon as the car Park's
open they'll be in there so it hasn't
been signed according to this report
well only only in terms of the lease
because it's not been handed back to the
council it'll be a seamless process once
the car Park's handed over great okay um
I had a few other questions
um in terms of again access to this for
the people who need it most I see there
is
um some information here about people
who have who are on the motability
scheme but I'm wondering about blue
badge holders
um as we know that they might have more
difficulty and with lots of different
things are we taking that into account
in in is there any special allowance for
blue badge holders or anything like that
I mean obviously a lot of our charges
currently are in car Parks so we should
be able to allow them to park in those
spaces as well I I think that's probably
a body of work for us to do there in
terms of scoping
um demand and what the specific needs
are I'd say that my sister's a really
large motability car user and I think we
need to look at what the actual offer is
in terms of the vehicles themselves
understand how much uptake there is so I
think that it will form part of a much
bigger parcel of work for us to properly
understand that issue I think well
obviously yeah
um okay um doses as we've exhausted the
easy options and cancel on car Parks but
I see big places like Stratford Mall and
Stanford quarter aren't mentioned here I
mean the Stratford Mall has I think
hundreds of empty car parking spaces
every day I know there are other issues
like electricity and stuff but surely
there are other low-hanging fruits there
we all grab for it uh yes Stratford
Stratford Mall we have we we certainly
have some plans for to uh to do it the
one of one of the issues there is a
really development
um because the redevelopments of
Stratford Mall unfortunately for the uh
for the construction of it uh will take
up quite a bit of the car park and
actually locating that locating the um
the electric charges in a place where
somebody's not going to build a compound
around it or rpr is easily accessible is
is our major issue there but without a
doubt Stratford Stratford Mall will
stand for quarter our in our minds as as
places to go
um one of one of the um in terms of in
terms of low hanging fruit I can't
stress the power problem uh enough
um it's not through one to try in the in
the in those in those places because we
have uh we have exhausted something
along the lines of about 60 sites where
where basically the power's not been not
been to a fitting off standard to do it
needs that much power that say in
Stanford quarter you can't put in just
two charges nothing Stanford I'm not
gonna I'm not going to quote on that one
because that is something that is
somewhere that we uh that we do want to
do want to uh to uh put it in when it's
when it's achievable so uh some some
button but in terms of it says a lot of
the a lot of the other sites that we've
gone through there is that there have
been something along the lines and along
the lines on the lines of 60 that we've
actually had to throw up we just not had
the power to do it so why is it not
tubal that's why I'm trying to work out
because it says here we've exhausted the
canceling place it's way way is safe to
stand for a quarter not achievable well
in terms of Stanford quarter we'll we'll
have a look and we'll we'll come back to
you with it with the actual the actual
detail on it um the um in terms of um in
terms of actual the the
um
uh the actual Council on car Parks the
ones that ones that we've gone through
are the ones that are the ones that we
currently have in Phase One a phase one
b and two are actually uh are actually
all the ones that we can physically
um put in due to uh without any
landowning owner problems or any power
only Power problems which which leads us
on to the second part of the report
which was what's next so uh so
realistically it was looking at the
Gable ends and the street parking where
we've not got clashes to uh to make sure
that we uh we fill the Gap in the
hundred okay
um a few more I won't keep everyone
alive
um I was
um taken with Jed's optimism about
giving 12 months to here the council's
position on the wires because I have
literally going to every exact paper
that has been written on this basically
one a year and asking the same question
and being told we will have it in the
next report and I always say as well and
we need to tie this in with car clubs
because as I think Kent's Oxford said
and we can't just kind of keep this
model of everyone has their own car and
they have this way of putting fuel and
Power in it and it just we just have
more and more cars in these terrorist
streets there just isn't room and it's
not feasible we need to change our whole
model here and if we in you know
integrated our plans for electric cars
with a substantial rollout of a car club
that could be done at very little cost
at the council it would be you know
privately done because we could really
change on the car clubs and local
Authority has already responded to a
consultation by the combined or
Authority about expressions of interest
in forming a greater manchester-wide car
club and we we've expressed well I think
corporate directive places expressed
that we are interested in participating
in that and it's in the early stages I
think they're looking at costing it in
August 2023 with a potential for
evolving out from Autumn 2023 so
certainly I'd be happy to come back with
more information the scrutiny committee
is that work proceeds
[Music]
Manchester and Salford have a car club
set up for many years we have all those
empty spaces sat there in Stratford Mall
that the council could be getting money
for renting out to a car club you know
it just doesn't need to come anyway and
final thing I would say is on the lamp
posts and the digging holes in the
ground and I wonder about the digging
housing Grant if
um wireless charging will come in by the
time all the holes are broken we'll then
just have a load of
um holes in the ground and on the
Lamppost My worry is always about
pavement clutter and we know how
difficult it is for people who have
difficulties their size or difficult
Mobility to get around and we don't need
to make that worse yeah thank you
I certainly agree with the last Point
around the around the footways I think I
think as I mentioned before in the high
amp
part of it we're very conscious of the
uh of basically the impacts of footways
on uh that was on disability
um on disability groups and anybody that
struggles with moving
um and to try and keep that keep that as
open as possible
um a proliferation of of wires however
protected well no it would not uh will
not stand up to scrutiny I think to uh
in in terms of uh in terms of disability
groups at all uh so that's why that's
why we've aired on on that on that
particular bit
um what I would say is that is that um
boy made about about the yearly yearly
basis I think in the last year though we
have we have accelerated the amount of
uh amounts of uh charges that we've put
in we're currently we're currently we
sit just behind Manchester in terms of
the amount that we've uh that we've
placed and um
I'm looking forward with the with with
phase 1v2 to hopefully overtaking them
and making sure that we we
um well probably not doing enough in
terms of it in terms of putting uh
putting this on the on the floor and I
think there is a responsibility for uh
for the private sector to actually step
twice you step in within that and I'm
fairly sure they will uh but what uh
what we did want to do uh with this is
to make a um is to make a real conscious
effort uh to make sure that we'd uh
we've got
um some or a start of evg EV charging
technology out across the uh across the
area which hopefully in the next by the
time by the time the next one comes
along we will have we will have achieved
the uh achieved all all that we can do
within phase one p and phase two
foreign
for the presentation I think there is a
a lot of work to be done uh but I think
technology is moving so fast you know we
might we we we might have electric cars
that recharge themselves at some point
and then we won't need
yeah yeah exactly
um right but but uh
thank thank you for coming along and uh
you know I'm presenting and answering
the questions uh really appreciate that
uh we we we're on item eight now uh
committee work program so if if uh the
exact members and the officers want to
uh disappear that's uh okay with with me
yeah
um you put your hand up
yeah I'd like to um request that we do a
task and finish group on all right very
topical subject of reducing car usage
which has been talked about a lot
um not so much focusing on active travel
on issues such as promoting buses
looking at parking
issues workplace parking levels that
kind of thing so I would like to suggest
that we we do one
um if that if everybody's in agreement
with that task and finish group yeah to
to look at all those issues basically uh
around uh cars and how we can improve
um you know the the whole aspect of
uh you know cars and
um
what we we do with parking and yeah or
all of that really
yeah yeah is everybody happy in relation
to developing a task and finish group
yeah Alex
um is that to be done in the next uh
Municipal year it's just at the moment
I I like I struggled to keep up with
what we've got on at the moment without
adding an additional group
um
I say we're currently down a couple of
members of stuff we're hoping that that
will be resolved soon and that we'll be
able to offer more capacity but really I
mean um
they say with the minutes and stuff
coming through late it is due to we are
just struggling at the moment and an
additional task and finish group I don't
think would be able to Resource it
particularly well I mean if you talk to
councilor when Stanley like he did an
amazing piece of work on the disability
access by himself and like drove that by
pretty much by himself and that's
something that you could look to do as
and use the
um committee basically as just a way to
get your recommendations from the work
that you do into the executive uh so
I'll talk to him about that but yeah in
terms of like officer support I really
can't offer you the spot that you'd
require to to do that at this point in
time so to be clear then so we can do it
without the officer support yeah yes yes
we can I'm interested yeah yeah and you
can still come to me ask questions and
stuff like that but I won't be able to
like Arrangements yeah be happy with
that yeah anybody else is interested
thank you so
um obviously if if we're agreed that
that's what we we do then Alex can put
an email out to ask for members to
actually join that task and finish group
would you be willing to chair the such a
task and finish group
yeah
so I don't know whether anybody wants to
volunteer now I mean we'd have to scope
it obviously
um
yeah you you you would be interested
and counselor fasted use
no but
no but
well it's not an informal it is formal
um but we would have to do the work
ourselves really and if there is a group
you know group of members then we could
do it through uh teams meetings and and
things like that at least be able to
you know scope the the the the the work
and
um begin to think about how how we can
actually
um you know yeah we can look at look
what other councils are doing and we can
discuss ideas and yeah bring forward
some recommendations yeah and then in
the new Municipal year we'll we'll have
probably more support from officers as
well so it's just getting started really
with it and uh rather than waiting to
the new Municipal year if if we're happy
to do that yeah
okay
so if KKK Alex will put um you know an
email around asking for volunteers to
sit on that task and finish group
I'll put in that that our volunteers
it's a contact yeah the chat just so you
know who's there and then I say if you
can want to put together meetings but if
you know when you want to do things like
I'm happy to support
um with little bits and pieces yeah
is that okay
is there anything on the work program
that anybody wants to raise
are we okay with it yeah
um so urgent business I don't have any
um and so that actually completes our
meeting
um can I thank you all
for
your attendance tonight and your
contributions
um I think there's
some interesting
presentations today and some interesting
comments from members and I think we we
will put something together particularly
on the
um the
um asset management of uh of the roads
and everything
um because I think
members do have a lot of input in terms
of
what they see and whether
the officers do capture you know what
the members are saying and you know
around the leaf clearing and all of
those kind of things and the drainage
and
um
we you know we we see it in areas and
yes we know that
the the the the surface water when it
rains heavily it'll go down eventually
but some go down
quicker than others and I think that's
the point really and you actually know
where where you pinpoint those things
but anyway we'll we'll try and put
something together and share it with
with members
um you know that we could actually put a
bit more pressure on onto the office in
offices in terms of
uh how how we can maybe improve the
services that we get
yeah
that well that's what I was thinking
that you know I think you want some
outcome don't you really yes having sat
through
here
well we're well put I think yeah okay
then so thanks very much again and have
a safe journey home
foreign